The Marvel Cinematic Universe
just got a whole lot… smaller.
The release of the first full trailer for
"Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania" is here,
but say goodbye to that lighthearted
tone from the first two Ant-Man movies.
Starring Paul Rudd as Scott Lang, aka Ant-Man, and
Evangeline Lilly as Hope Van Dyne, aka the Wasp,
this latest entry in the MCU depicts the
size-shifting team returning to the Quantum
Realm after Cassie Lang accidentally opens
a rift to the realm and drags them all in.
"Wait – wait a minute. You're sending a signal
down to the Quantum Realm. Turn it off."
Also along for the ride are the previous Ant-Man
and the Wasp, Dr. Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne,
both of whom are probably dreaming of
superhero retirement by this point.
Unfortunately for our heroes, it
seems as though the Quantum Zone
has its own array of inhabitants,
including Bill Murray — whose role
is as yet a mystery — and a variant of Kang
the Conqueror, the MCU's newest big baddie.
Oh, a quick aside, we're calling him a
"variant" because Kang's whole deal is
that the Marvel multiverse is drowning in
Kangs, almost all of whom seem to be a kind
of tyrannical warlord. Before this trailer,
we'd only seen Kang in the Disney+ series
"Loki," where the variant was a relatively
peaceful fellow at the end of the world.
Now, with "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania"
showcasing just how intimidating Kang the
Conqueror can truly be, fans are eager to share
their opinions about the green-clad menace.
One user reacted to the
trailer on Twitter by saying,
"CGI is on point. Also, Kang looks sick,
can't wait to see him pulverize Ant-Man!"
Another poster, charmingly
hopeful, responded by saying,
"Kang is gonna be the best marvel villain."
Less hopeful, another user retweeted the new
poster for "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania,"
which depicts Kang holding the tiny heroes atop
his middle finger like bread crumbs, saying,
"I've got a horrible feeling
Kang is going to K-word Scott."
"Kill! … YES!"
That's actually
a pretty common theory, by the way. The notion
that Kang will be this brutally merciless
killer is so prevalent that some outlets have
practically pre-written obituaries for Scott Lang.
It wouldn't be out of nowhere. Every time a
new major villain is introduced in the MCU,
they have to make a noticeable first
impression somehow. For comparison,
the mad titan Thanos killed Loki and Heimdall
in his first bout against the Avengers. There's
just no way that everyone in "Ant-Man and the
Wasp: Quantumania" is making it out alive.
One Twitter user predicted an entire multi-movie
arc for the conflict with Kang, saying,
"I can see every movie Kang is in, ending with
some sort of defeat, and then another Kang
variant just poppin in and they back to square one
[...] That would be sick. A never ending cycle."
"Feels like a fresh start."
A recent feature from Men's Health gives
us a pretty good look at the mentality that
Jonathon Majors is taking in his approach
to portraying Kang. The interview reminds
us that Majors is well-known for
immersing himself within a role,
bringing both an intense work ethic and
even more intense energy to his work.
When discussing his all-in approach, Majors said,
"I have a tremendous amount of faith in my
preparation and faith in something greater
than me ... And not because my ego
tells me I am but because I’m ready."
Crucially for a superhero movie, he boasted,
"I know I can take my shirt off."
The actor went on to describe how he'd
run countless miles, abstained from carbs,
and put his body on the line honing his physique
to the bare minimum of what comic book audiences
expect of their fearsome villains. He
also discussed how he worked with his
strength conditioning coach specifically
to create an "imposing figure" for Kang.
Already there's at least one major movie on the
horizon set to center on Kang after "Ant-Man and
the Wasp: Quantumania." With the help of Majors
and his fitness coaches, we're sure audiences
will be gladly fearing all the variations
of this imposing figure for years to come.